[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
modeling of cellular interactions in
mixed murain organoids
i am kayleigh bach of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by andor
to learn more please visit
andor.oxinst.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
saskia zalkerbauk
assistant professor at utrecht
university
sasukiya you may now begin your
presentation
first of all i would like to thank endor
for this opportunity to present our work
i recently started my lab at utrecht
university
and most of this work was done when we
were still at the netherlands cancer
institute in amsterdam under the wings
of jakovareina
what i would like to show today is how
competitive cell interactions can
influence oncogenic growth in mixed
intestinal organoids
within tissues cells continuously
compare their fitness with that of their
neighboring cells weaker or looser cells
are identified by stronger winter cells
and
eliminated from these tissues often
through apoptosis
and this is a strong mechanism that
controls overall tissue and organismal
fitness which was first identified in
developing flight tissues in the 70s
but it can act as a regulator of quality
control throughout organismal life
and this starts in early embryo and
continues to impact physiology to late
adulthood
but cell condition competition has also
been shown to protect against disease
for example by
elimination of early malignant cells
from pancreatic or intestinal epithelia
or through cell selection in the timers
which can protect against leukemia
however on the other side of the
spectrum we and others have shown that
cancer cells can use cell competition
for their own benefit and this is
exactly what my lab is currently focused
on
and this is all driven by differences in
cellular fitness and what this means i
would like to illustrate by two pieces
of work that i contributed to as a
postdoc in the lab of eugenia padini in
the gerding institute in cambridge where
we started cell competition in the
intestinal of the fruit fly
and what we found is that cells that
have a ribosome impairment also known as
minute cells are eliminated by
surrounding wall type enterocytes
however the same wall type enterocytes
themselves are eliminated when they are
facing abc mutant cells
and this is super interesting because
genetically these wild
cells are identical but their survival
is fully dependent on the fitness of
their neighbors
in order to study such competitive
behavior of cell populations we set out
to develop a model system based on urine
intestinal organoids
and what we do is first derive organoid
lines with a different cellular fitness
for example of a wild type and of a
cancer origin
and next we label these cells
differentially with fluorescent markers
these cultures are then broken into
either pieces or single cells mixed and
formed into 3d mixed organoids or
moreno layers
and these populations can then be
followed over time on both a population
or a cellular level
and for now i will first focus on the
mixed entered monolayers
we decided to use these to evaluate a
role for cell competition in colorectal
cancer and therefore we derived small
intestine organoids of a wild type
nature that are labeled in magenta
throughout this presentation
and we derived organoids of a cancer
origin that lack abc our p53 mutant and
express oncogenic k-ras and these will
be labeled in green throughout
and an example of such a monolayer is
shown here on the right
when we analyzed the behavior of these
different cell populations in these
cultures we observed something
interesting because where pure
populations of violet cells happily
expand and mature
instead the mixed population
in mixed populations this water
population is gradually lost over time
when we have a closer look at these
monolayers
we observe that these wild type cells
reduce both in size and an example is
outlined here in cyan on the right
and in number and
a cell that is disappearing is shown in
magenta on the right
and therefore
this indicates that t cells are
eliminated from these monolayers and
this prompted us to have a closer look
at and evaluate markers of cell death
such as cleave gas base 3.
what we found is that where pure
populations of either walter or
cancer cells
showed very little activation of this
marker of cell death
instead
this um
there's a marked increase in the amount
of cleavpest gas-based positive wildlife
cells in mixed conditions indicating
that these cells are eliminated by
cancer cells in an apoptosis dependent
manner
of course we were very interested to see
what the influence of cell competition
is on cataracts of cancer and near
native conditions and therefore we next
turn to
these 3d mixed cultures
and for this we use the same multi
population that we previously used in
the
android monolayers that again are
labeled in magenta and the same cancer
population that are marked in green
but instead we generated these 3d
mixed
mixed cultures
and an example of this is shown here on
the right
first i would like you to focus on the
water population in these cultures
because what we observed is that where
pure populations
happily grow they mature they expand
they form these crypt-like structures
exactly how you what you would expect
from a wild type intestinal population
instead the mixed wild-type population
is lost from these cultures over time
which is shown in the decrease here in
the craft on the right
in fact when we quantify the
contribution of the vatican population
to these organizers over time we
observed that there's a lower
amount of all-type cells at the end of
the experiment than there is at the
beginning of the experiment and this
showed us that the water population is
actively eliminated from these organoids
and it's not not just a mere passive
difference in proliferation rate
in order to
characterize what happens to these cells
we had a closer look at the fatal pile
types and we found that cells were
extruded
from the epithelia
and that there is an accumulation of
cell wall type cell debris in the lumen
indicating that these cells are
eliminated through cell death and
therefore we had a closer look at
markers of apoptosis
and what we found is that in the mixed
populations there's an increase in the
amount of cleave gas-based positive
cells showing that they are indeed
eliminated through apoptosis and
interestingly we could
see activation of this microbot at the
interface with cancer cells but also
further away in the inner cell mass
and even though elimination of water
cells can be induced at a distance from
these cancer cells multiple lines of
evidence suggest that cell competition
is actually short-ranged
because
what we found is that
first of all
the water population and the cancer
population are part of the same
epithelium and these competing cell
populations directly interact and
closely intermingle
second
we could observe occasional organoids of
a pure water organ origin
nearby mixed organoids suggesting that
elimination of vault-up cells depends on
intraorganoid interactions with cancer
cells
and lastly the growth and the behavior
of pure bottle conditions that are
plated in the same well with pure cancer
or mixed organoids were
undistinguishable of solely pure wild
type cultures indicating that the
process of both both cell populations
within the same organoid is required for
our competition of wildlife cells
importantly when we next treated these
mixed cultures with a caspase inhibitor
this could protect about the population
and it increases the contribution of the
vata population two mixed organoids and
therefore this altogether told us that
intestinal cells are actively eliminated
by cancer cells through apoptosis
so far i have shown you that the
presence of cancer cells has a negative
influence on what's up intestine cells
but is there an effect of these
competitive interactions on the cancer
population as well
and therefore i would like to shift your
attention to
the other population in these cultures
and what we observed is that
there is a higher expansion rate
of cancer cells in mixed conditions
compared to the behavior or the
expanding rate of cancer cells in pure
conditions
suggesting that there might be
proliferative advantage for cancer cells
by
the elimination of file types
and to further dive into this we looked
at different markers of cell cycle
progression and we found that cancer
cells have a higher rate of cycling
cells in mixed conditions
and we observed that cells are more
likely to progress from s-phase to
mitosis in a period of four hours and
that there are higher rates of mitotic
cells
and all together this shows us that
cancer cells use competitive cellular
interactions to boost their growth
what i've shown you so far is that
competitive cell interactions shape the
behavior of both wild type and cancer
cells when they're in mixed conditions
and to get a better understanding of
what derives these interactions we
decided to sort of all-type cells from
pure and mixed conditions and next
subject these cells to bulk mrna
sequencing
what we found is that overall cell
competition induces expression of genes
that are involved in cell death
while genes that are involved in cell
cycle
and
metabolism are repressed and this was
very reassuring because of course this
is exactly what you would expect from a
population that is being out-competed
however when we started to have a look
at the individual genes that were
differentially expressed in these mixed
populations we really got excited
because this is what
because what caught our attention is the
increased expression of two particular
gene families
that will fly six and a nexin
and this was particularly interesting to
us because in the past years multiple
labs have shown that these genes are
part of a signature that is induced in
intestinal tissues upon different
damaging insults
and what they showed is that for example
colitis or an infection with parasitic
helminths
can cause reversion of cells to a
fetal-like state
and this helps the tissue to cope with
this stress
and indeed when we compared our dataset
to a previously published data set
we found a clear enrichment indicating
that cell competition might
cause a similar response and induce this
fetal-like state or damaging state
in intestinal wild-type cells
to further investigate this response we
went back to our mixed cultures
and we found that a main marker of this
response lie 6 which is also known as
sca1 is highly expressed in mixed wild
type cells
um shown here on the on the picture in
the middle but also in the
quantification on the right
uh while
pure wild type cells are completely
devoid of this expression of this marker
and this indicates that indeed volatile
cells refer to a primitive fetal-like
state when they are in close proximity
of cancer cells
another correct characteristic of this
response is the loss of cell types that
are normally present in adult and
intestinal tissues such as stem cells
and interestingly in our mixed cultures
we observe that the while the population
undergoes a morphological change it
loses these typical crypt-like
structures that are normally present in
intestinal organoids
and this also coincides within a
reduction in the number of cells that
are positive for the stem cell marker
lcr5
confirming that during competition
mature cell types are lost in the wilder
population
and these cells refer to a primitive
fetal-like state
well
because this happens and we see this
reversion we speculated that possibly
self-state transition might contribute
to competition and therefore we had a
look and further investigated how we
could possibly manipulate this
and
one of the methods that we tried is to
a previously reported
treatment of chiron and vulproic acid
and what has been shown in the past is
that this could enrich for stem cells in
intestinal cultures and indeed also in
our hands we saw a massive increase in
the amount of lgr5 positive cells as
shown in the pictures here so this is
with treatment in the middle
but also in the quantification on the
right
of course we next wondered whether this
had a functional effect on competition
and
the phenotypes that we observed before
and therefore we had a look at
activation of scavon and we
found that
enrichment of the stem cell population
could prevent
the induction of scal1 and
in mixed water cells indicating that
indeed
this combined treatment of chiron and
velbroic acid can prevent this
transition to a fetal-like state
and importantly when we next evaluated
the impact of prevention of this cell
state transition to the outcome of
competition we found that this is
sufficient to protect the wild
populations and prevent their
elimination
as confirmed by the quantification here
importantly
this prevention of competition did not
only influence the wilder population but
it could also take away the competitive
advantage of cancer cells and limit our
over-proliferation rate and together
this told us that during competition
all-type cells refer to a primitive cell
state which can be used by cancer cells
to promote promote their proliferative
capacity
next to get insight into the mechanisms
that might drive this we went back to
our mrna sequencing data what we found
is that apis monsights are enriched in
genes that are differentially expressed
in mixed wild type cells
these ap1 sites are bound by a
heterodymeric transcription factor
complex containing for example cto
and therefore we next wondered whether
there's a differential behavior of this
particular transcription factor in
competing cells
and we use this phosphor-specific
antibody that recognizes the activated
form of the protein and can be
recognized by nuclear
localization
and what we observed is that cancer
cells
show a heterogeneous high expression of
high activation of siege
irrespective of competition we can
observe this in the pure conditions but
also in the mixed conditions
however what we found is that there is a
little activation of c john in pure wild
type cells
but there is an increased activation of
this nuclear transcription factor in
mixed wild populations also reflected
here in the quantification on the left
interestingly when we had a closer look
at these phosphogen positive cells we
saw that the distance of cancer cells is
lower
and that there's an enrichment of
activated
cells water cells that are in close
proximity of cancer cells together
indicating that short-range signals from
cancer cells can be involved in the
activation of
c john
and this activation was particularly
interesting to us because c john is a
downstream target of j k kinase
which is activated as a response to a
wide range of cellular stressors but is
also known
as a regulator of many different types
of cell competition
and therefore we next wondered whether
jk signaling is involved in cell
competition in this system
and what we did first is treat our
cultures
with a small molecule that specifically
inhibits the jnk kinase
and this treatment was sufficient to
prevent preventive reversion
of
wildlife cells to a fetal like state
upon competition
giving us the first indication that jnk
might be involved in our competition of
vital cells
next
what we found is that j-inking
inhibition could prevent elimination of
volatile cells
therefore confirming a role for jnk
signaling
in cell competition in intestinal
organoids
however treatment with a small molecule
inhibitor
targets both cancer cells and wild-type
cells and indeed
when we have a look at phosphogen
in these populations we see that
treatment with this inhibitor
completely abolishes the staining
with this specific antibody in wild-type
cells
also shown here
but also in the cancer population shown
here and therefore with an experiment
like this we are unable to untangle in
which of these cell populations j and k
activation is involved
so therefore we designed a method that
we can use to specifically inhibit jnk
signaling in an individual cell
populations
and what we decided to do
is use inducible expression of a
phosphatase that can inhibit the chain k
kinase known as mkp5 or dosptan
and using a doxycycline inducible system
we can thereby target the nk signaling
in either cancer cells or in wild type
cells
first we
expressed a
only in the cancer population and what
we saw is that
treating these cultures with doxycycline
did not affect
competition at all
so
the amount of volatile cells that are
present in these organoids is unchanged
and the ratio is not affected indicating
that j k signalling is not needed
in the cancer population
however when we next inhibited jk
activation solely in the wilder
population
we saw a major striking effect
because
this prevented the elimination of the
water population
showing us that cell competition
activates jnk in wild-type cells and
that this is required for their
elimination
in summary what i've shown today is that
wildlife intestine cells are actively
eliminated by cancer cells
and this results in induction of a
fetal-like state which is driven by jnk
signaling in the in valta population
importantly inhibition of competition
through preventing the cell state
transition or through inhibiting jnk
signaling can protect about that
population
but it also limits the oncogenic growth
of cancer cells
and
which of course opens up a very
interesting window for treatment options
because instead of targeting tumor cells
directly with the possible side effects
that come with this
instead we can envision that inhibiting
competition can simultaneously protect
the surrounding healthy tissue while
limiting tumor growth
and with this i would like to close by
thanking a lot of people first of all i
recently started my lab at utrecht
university but this work was and most of
this work was done under the wings of
jakob fahren at the netherlands cancer
institute
with the help of a lot of collaborators
that is shown here on the right
and it was financially supported by the
dutch cancer society and in particular i
would like to thank other culture garcia
who did a large part of this work and
kindly joined me in israel
when i moved my lab
there thank you
thank you saskia for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
all right let's get started our first
question here asks
is there a possibility to adjust the
ratio of the different cell populations
in mixed organoids
hi kaylee thank you for um moderating
this session and for this question
uh yeah this is a
a very interesting um part of the the
procedure that we use
and
practically it is
a bit difficult because um it really
depends on the behavior of the
individual cell populations themselves
in case
they are relatively
equal in fitness
the ratio is very easy to adjust because
then you can play with
single cell
suspensions
um in the case of the small intestine
we really needed to
work with pieces of organoids to
generate these mixed organoids which
makes it a lot more difficult to
work with different
actual ratios
of course by using live imaging one can
visualize organoids from the start with
different ratios and
follow those over time which would solve
this question
great thank you
all right our next question here asks
which kind of microscope do you use
image mixed organoids in 3d
yes
we actually use
two different types of microscopes
depending on the question that we would
like to answer
so for live imaging which is a large
part of our work
we love to use spinning discs and
our favorite one
that we did most of the imaging on is
the
dragonfly from andor
and so this really allows rapid
imaging
over time in 3d
for the fixed images we normally use
scanning
scanning confocals
yeah depending on on the question to be
asked
great thank you
all right our next question here says
related to the previous question how do
you visualize the data after acquisition
yeah this is of course very important as
well microscopy is not just
dependent on
[Music]
the microscope that you use but also a
lot of it is data analysis afterwards
so
especially when we're talking about
time-lapse imaging this is massive
amounts of data
and
we find that the best way to process
this is using
software that can
do
3d reconstructions of these different
stacks that you acquire over time
and
most of this work was done using the
image software from
bitlain which is now
oxford scientific i think
great
we have another question here that asks
is the observed phenotype specific to
colorectal cancer with this specific
combination of mutations
yeah so this is something we of course
were wondering as well you
you want to make sure that
this is not just something that you see
with one particular type of cells
but in fact we we've used
multiple different combinations of
mutations and they also show same
similar phenotypes
meaning that we can see that
these
different types of cancer cells can
eliminate wild-type cells in the
apoptosis dependent manner and they all
induce a fetal-like state
great thank you
it looks like we have another question
here that asked can engraftment of
cancer cells onto wild-type cell layers
be prevented by increasing fitness of
wild-type cells
yeah this is super interesting of course
in particular when you're thinking about
treatment options and
we think
you can
based on the data that we
have uh using apoptosis inhibitors for
example or inhibiting of
jnk signaling because this basically
prevents the out competition of these
wild-type cells but also makes them
stronger
and this also prevents the overgrowth of
cancer cells in this
situation so
there is a possibility that this
definitely works yeah
all right well we'll go ahead and wrap
up with that final question there thank
you again saskia for your time today and
your important research we'd also like
to thank lab roots and our sponsor andor
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone bye
you